en la figura el triángulo a veces
isósceles
este es el triángulo a veces y un
triángulo isósceles tiene dos de sus
lados congruentes o tienen la misma
longitud y justo es lo que explican a
continuación es decir que el lado ave
este lado de acá tiene la misma longitud
que el lado bc
estos dos lados miden lo mismo el
triángulo de eje que es éste está sobre
puesto con el triángulo abc eso lo vemos
en la gráfica con estos dos triángulos
que forman una estrella ladeada cuál es
el valor del ángulo p vamos a resolverlo
el triángulo abc es un triángulo
isósceles y lo vamos a dibujar por
separado aquí en un triángulo isósceles
si estos dos lados miden lo mismo
entonces los ángulos de la base van a
ser congruentes nos dicen que el ángulo
de acá es de 100 grados y sabemos que la
suma de todos los ángulos internos de un
triángulo siempre es igual a 180 grados
si aquí tenemos x grados y acá también
tenemos x grados
entonces x x más 100 grados tiene que
ser igual a 108
grados simplificamos esto y nos queda 2x
si restamos 100 de ambos lados resulta
180 menos 100 igual a 80 finalmente
tenemos que x es igual a 40 grados pues
dividimos ambos lados entre 2 de esta
forma encontramos que estos dos ángulos
miden 40 grados y nos dimos cuenta de
esto porque sabemos que el triángulo abc
es un triángulo isósceles por lo que
estos ángulos en la base son congruentes
ahora analicemos este pequeño triángulo
de acá nuevamente ya sabemos que la suma
de los ángulos internos de cualquier
triángulo siempre es igual a 180 grados
este ángulo de acá es el mismo que el
ángulo p ya que son ángulos verticales
este ángulo mide grados también p más 40
más sesenta debe ser igual a 180 grados
pues es la suma de los ángulos internos
del triángulo pequeño si simplificamos
tenemos p más 40 más 60 es 100 de más
100 es igual a 180 restamos 100 en ambos
lados de la igualdad y obtenemos p igual
80 grados cuál es el valor del ángulo p
el valor de esos 80 grados nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo